nosotros estamos en nuestro cuarto
tenemos la luz prendida obviamente
porque la necesitamos pero no vamos a
tener la luz prendida de la cocina
porque porque no la necesitamos nosotros
estamos a nuestro cuarto con esta luz de
esta manera la frase que dijo se podría
interpretar el cerebro solo utiliza las
partes que necesita utilizar imagínense
que estamos estudiando matemáticas
historia alguna clase de la escuela idea
nada te empiezas a poner como que
nervioso estás tienes miedo esto no pasa
porque porque en cero ahora me atrás
estudias solamente tiene activado
aquellas funciones que le permiten
aprender que le permiten todo ese tipo
de cosas pero por obvias razones no va a
tener prendido aquellas funciones que te
hacen estar en alerta por ejemplo estar
nervioso ese tipo de cosas esto no pasa
el cerebro tiene sus maneras de
organizar las cosas y como la explique
con las luces solamente va a tener
ciertas luces prendidas pero procesando
la frase que dijo este autor la
inteligencia no se puede medir
matemáticamente la inteligencia del
humano técnica
es infinita pero también surge un
problema aquí que el cerebro es casi
igual de complicado de entender que al
principio con nosotros con la álgebra a
mi paso que en primer grado yo estaba
feliz con la maestra llegue le dije oye
mis ya quiero ver álgebra es muy
divertido tremendo error que cometí
porque el año siguiente fue una de las
cuartas cosas he visto
este extremadamente complicado aprender
sobre álgebra al igual que el ser humano
tiene tantas limitaciones tiene tantas
cosas nuevas que a los científicos a
todos se nos complica mucho entender qué
sucede aquí dicho muchas cosas se
contradicen es tremendamente difícil
entender el cerebro pero bueno algo
fácil que podemos entender todos son las
neuronas las neuronas se puede decir que
son como información literalmente
bolitas de información veamos nuestro
cartel de 'se e imagínense que cada
vuelta es una neurona y cada neurona
contiene información distinta tal vez
información sobre desarrollo e
información sobre cualquier cosa pero el
punto es que cada neurona es diferente y
tiene un funcionamiento diferente esto
hasta ahí está fácil pero luego empiezan
las cosas complicadas están las redes
neuronales está cómo funciona el
aprendizaje y aquí es donde se complica
todo
aquí es donde dices no este tema cómo
que no como raro entonces me puse a
pensar qué tanto podemos explotar
nuestro conocimiento qué tal
él y gente somos la respuesta a que en
contra de esto es que el ser humano
tiene aquella habilidad de ser
infinitamente inteligente es decir que
siempre estará proyecta una información
que siempre puede aprender nuevas cosas
que nosotros somos capaces de lograr
técnicamente cualquier cosa pero
entonces también esto me llevó a otra
pregunta porque entonces los 67 millones
de habitantes que están actualmente
porque no todos somos unos minutos
porque no todos somos capaces de
exportar nuestro potencial no entiendo
qué pasa porque no todos somos capaces
de utilizar nuestro cerebro si es tan
complejo si es tan inteligente y la
verdad es que después de mucho tiempo
esta respuesta no existen muchos
científicos muchos neurólogos muchos
famosos ha intentado buscar aquella
respuesta porque no somos capaces de las
cosas y la verdad la respuesta no puede
responder los eso una vez un filósofo
dijo que el cerebro era tan complejo que
nosotros no podemos entenderlo que
procesaba más información de la que
podían y la verdad es que en ese tiempo
la gente lo atacó porque
es algo improbable cómo es posible que
el cerebro por sistemas de lo que puede
simplemente esto no es posible para al
pasar los años la gente se empezó a dar
cuenta que tal vez esto era cierto que
el cerebro era tan complejo que nosotros
no podíamos entenderlo y entonces esto
me dio investigar un poquito más
quisieron los grandes genios como
einstein u otras personas para lograr lo
que hicieron y vamos a uno de mis
principios favoritos el principio de de
nash jonas fue un matemático muy
importante durante su época él siempre
quiso buscar algo que la diferencia de
los demás algo que dijeran esto sólo es
mío eso no es tuyo -las él era es
trabajaba bueno estudiaba en una
universidad prestigiosa para que sus
compañeros le decían muy seguido yo
trabajé en la nasa y metió estoy
trabajando en este trabajo súper
importante estoy en el gobierno y cosas
así
y jonas le decían gusta mí no me importa
porque lo que tú estás haciendo son
cosas de los demás
tuve inventaste nada nuevo tunas
lograron nada yo no quiero hacer como
ellos le quiere aumentar algo años
después yo nací inventa lo que se la
conoce
al principio de nash algo totalmente
nuevo y lo que me fascina de este autor
intelectual es que supera parte de su
cerebro porque porque sufría de algete
alzheimer's esta persona tenía
restricciones de su cerebro él no podía
hacer las cosas como los demás pero éste
dijo no sabes que yo no creo ser como
los demás
yo quiero aprender algo nuevo y entonces
esto me llevo las personas intelectuales
las personas que han logrado inventar
algo buscaron un camino nuevo un camino
que solamente fuera de ellos que nadie
se gustara a no trabajar para ellos que
totalmente fuera de ellos entonces
personas como newton talvez tesla fueron
personas que descubrieron sus cosas
gracias a que ellos decidieron seguir su
camino y aprender lo que ellos querían
cuántos de ustedes en su salón o al
menos en el pasado
conocían algún arte entre comidas que
estaba estaban en clases le preguntaba
en cierta cosa y te echaba un chorro
sobre el contexto histórico y toda la
cosa
digamos que te preguntan
qué es la gravedad y uno respondería a
la fuerza
pero es tenerte responde a es la brega
es este aquella cosa que existe entre el
espacio y tiempo que utiliza fuerzas de
no sé qué y tempestad explicar un chorro
y todo se queda mirando con cara de que
estás diciendo porque la verdad es que
muchos de esos temas no nos importan no
nos interesan tal vez no sé qué pasa
pero son temas tontas para muchos de
nosotros yo la verdad que es que esta
gente ese tipo de gente las admiro
porque tal vez sean son capaces de decir
cosas que los demás no pueden y siempre
ha hecho que uno diga estás diciendo no
entiendo que estás diciendo para mí es
fabuloso que alguien sea capaz de decir
algo nuevo algo de ellos algo que los
demás no sepan demás algo increíble es
por esto que yo creo que la razón por la
que no los podía explotado esto
potencial es porque la mayoría de
nosotros o al menos muchos de nosotros
se la pasa viviendo debajo de los demás
están buscando la inteligencia de los
demás no su propio camino esto es algo
muy raro porque
siegel que vienen los demás es aburrida
por ejemplo en la escuela seguir el
libro a cada rato es tremendamente
aburrida pero si tú pones investigar lo
que te gusta todo ese tipo de cosas te
empiezas a divertir te empieza a dar
cuenta que es tu pasión que puedes
descubrir algo aquí pues sí yo creo que
todos podemos descubrir algo que todos
tenemos un einstein en nuestra cabeza
pero simplemente hace falta crear
nuestro camino sin que nadie nos diga
nada no importa que sea la teoría de
quién sabe que que te explica un chorro
de cosas que a nadie le importa porque
él lo que importa aquí es que es tuya y
es que los demás no lo saben eso es lo
que yo quiero llegar nosotros tenemos un
cerebro inmensamente inteligente un
cerebro que es capaz de procesar
prácticamente todo lo que quiere
entonces que nos falta lo que nos falta
en la perspectiva la perspectiva de
encontrar las cosas por nuestra cuenta
gracias
[Aplausos]